Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
(Alkış)
Merhabalar.
Nam-ı diğer "Yaprak".
Bundan on dört sene önce,
sevgili Gülse Birsel
senaryoyu elime verdiğinde, Yaprak
karakterini aynen şöyle anlatıyordu:
Reikici,
enerji işleriyle uğraşan,
kişisel gelişim işlerine takık,
vejetaryen, yogacı.
14 sene önce sadece vejetaryen
ve yogacı ne demek anlamıştım.
Şimdi diyeceksiniz ki,
14 senede ne oldu da Hale bu hâle geldi;
şimdi kişisel gelişim uzmanı,
yaşam koçluğu ve iş koçluğu yapıyor?
Galatasaray Üniversitesi son sınıftayım,
sinema televizyon bölümü.
Bir yandan yönetmen yardımcılığı
yapıyorum,
öte yandan ufak tefek böyle dizilerde,
reklam filmlerinde oynuyorum
ve şunu anladım:
Ben kameranın arkasında olmak istemiyorum,
ben önünde olmak istiyorum.
Ben sevilen, sayılan, ünlü,
başarılı bir oyuncu olmak istiyorum.
Okul da bitmek üzere,
hemen Türkiye'de konservatuvar
okumaya karar verdim.
Dediler ki yaşlısın,
25 yaşından sonra Türkiye'de
konservatuvar okuyamıyorsun,
oyunculuk için geçti.
Kalakaldım.
O dönemde iki öğretmenim hayatımı
değiştiren bir seçim yaptırdılar bana.
Birisi ünlü oyuncu Cevdet Arıcılar,
diğeri belgesel yönetmeni
sevgili Enis Rıza Sakızlı.
Her ikisine de buradan
hürmetlerimi gönderiyorum.
Bir bir beni karşılarına aldılar
ve şunu söylediler,
"Hale sen bunu başarırsın.
Henüz paranın tadını almadan, öğrenci
psikolojisindeyken bas git yurtdışına,
oku oyuncu ol, hayalini gerçekleştir!"
Bastım gittim New York'a.
Hayalimi gerçekleştirdim,
ama gerçekleştirmek için
neler yaşadım bakın.
Kimlerin yatılı dadısı var evinde?
Bir yıl boyunca yatılı dadı oldum.
Duvar boyacılığı yaptım,
bildiğiniz duvar boyadım.
Köpek gezdirdim, temizlik yaptım,
tüm eğitim hayatım boyunca,
haftanın üç gecesi bir gece kulübünün
vestiyerinin vestiyer kızı oldum.
Buna rağmen de aç kaldım.
Hiç unutmuyorum,
bir gün iki saat bale dersi yaptık,
peşine iki saat eskrim yaptık,
ölüyorum açlıktan.
Sonra oyunculuk dersine gireceğiz,
bir saat öğle tatilimiz var.
Cebimde param yok,
arkadaşlarımın artıklarını kovaladım
öğrenci odasında,
böyle baktım ki biri bitiremese de
bir şeyler mideme girse.
Merak etmeyin, bir arkadaşım
fark etti durumu ve beni o öğlen doyurdu.
Hepsi ne için?
Sevilen, sayılan,
ünlü bir oyuncu olmak için.
Sonra Türkiye'ye döndüm,
İstanbul'da mücadele başladı.
E babamı iki yıl önce kaybetmiştim,
annem emekli öğretmen Samsun'da
yaşıyor ve İstanbul'da evim yok.
Elimde bir bavul,
on beş günde bir ev değiştirdim.
Arkadaşlarımın salonlarında kalıyordum,
ev sahibinin sıkıldığını hissettiğimde
pırr öteki eve!
Onun sıkıldığını hissettiğimde
Üç ay böyle evden eve dolaştım.
Derken çok sevdiğim
bir çocukluk arkadaşım bana evini açtı
ve evsizlik olayım çözüldü.
Hepsi ne için?
Sevilen, sayılan, ünlü,
başarılı bir oyuncu olmak için.
Altı ay sonra İstanbul
Gelişim Orkestrası'na girdim.
Atilla Özdemiroğlu, Garo Mafyan
gibi insanlarla şarkı söylemeye başladım.
Ondan altı ay sonra Avrupa Yakası oldu.
İki ay içinde Türkiye'nin en sevilen,
en sayılan, en ünlü,
en başarılı genç yüzlerinden
biri olmuştum!
Eee?
Çok mutlu olmam gerekmiyor muydu,
neler yaşadım bunu başarmak için!
Hayır.
Tam bir enkazdım.
Bir uçak kazası hayal edin,
enkazın sebeplerini öğrenmek için
ne yapılır?
Kara kutunun içindeki kayıtlar
deşifre edilir.
Şimdi söyleyeceğim çok önemli.
Kırmızı noktaya geri dönüyorum.
Bir:
Hepimizin içinde
kayıtlarla dolu bir kara kutu var.
Olumlu kayıtlar var,
olumsuz kayıtlar var.
Hayatınızın sevdiğiniz
ve sevmediğiniz yanlarını yaratan
bu olumlu ve olumsuz kayıtlar.
Şimdi size beni bugünkü ben yapan
kalbim hızlanmaya başladı,
kara kutumdaki en karanlık kaydı
deşifre edeceğim.
Ben 1974 yılında Almanya'da doğdum
ve eğer 80'ler yılında
Almanya'da çocuk olduysanız,
bir restoranın kapısında
şu yazıyı okumuşsunuzdur:
Türkler ve köpekler giremez.
Benim kara kutumda bu yazı kayıtlı.
Sırf Türk olduğum için,
okulda benimle arkadaşlık yapmak
istemeyen bir sürü çocuk oldu.
Yani varoluş şeklimden dolayı
ırkçılığa maruz kaldım.
Ama en karanlık kaydım bu değil.
7-8 yaşlarındayım,
annemle babam kulaklarımı deldirmiş,
amcam da Türkiye'den gerçek altın küpeler
hediye göndermiş top şeklinde
o zaman çok modaydı.
Hemen kulağıma taktım, okula gideceğim,
hava atacağım, çok heyecanlıyım!
Gittim okula,
böyle tekli sıralarımız var hepimizin,
oturdum.
Saçlarımı da böyle yaptım görsünler diye,
hemen oradan bir kız fark etti sabah.
Geldi, "Ay Hale küpelerin
ne kadar güzel," dedi.
"Teşekkür ederim, gerçek altın
amcam Almanya'dan gönderdi " dedim.
Oradan başka bir kız geldi.
"Hayır yalan söylüyorsun,
Türkiye'de altının ne işi var?" dedi.
"Hayır doğru söylüyorum,
onlar gerçek altın
ve amcam Türkiye'den gönderdi."
Sonra birdenbire ben görünmez oldum,
beni ne duydular,
ne dikkate aldılar, ne dinlediler.
Sınıf ikiye ayrıldı:
Bir grup onun savunduğu tarafta,
bir grup bunun savunduğu tarafta.
Bu diyor ki,
"Ya doğru söyleme ihtimali var,
belki de Türkiye'de altın vardır."
Kimden bahsediyorlarsa,
ben sanki orada yokum.
Bu da diyor ki,
"Hayır, kesinlikle yalan söylüyor.
Türkiye'de altının ne işi var?"
Sonra bir kobay hayvanı gibi
bir deney yapmaya karar verdiler.
İki yanımdan geldiler,
benim iznim olmadan küpelerimi kulağımdan
söktüler ve masanın üstüne koydular.
Tecavüze uğramak gibi.
Mıknatısla altının gerçek olup
olmadığını kontrol edecekler.
O sırada öğretmenimiz içeri girdi,
bütün sınıf dağıldı oturdu
ve bu anı, benim kara kutumun
en derinlerine öyle bir kayıt oldu ki
bayağı bir terapi aldım
ve çok fazla yaşam koçuna gittim,
yıllar sonra hatırladım bunu.
İşte o kayıt var ya,
o 7-8 yaşındaki kız çocuğu,
o kız çocuğu takdir edilmek istedi,
onaylanmak istedi,
dikkat çekmek istedi,
görünmek istedi;
kıyafetleriyle, taktıklarıyla
beğenilmek istedi.
Avrupa Yakası patladığında
Türkiye nüfusu 60 milyondu,
ben 60 milyonun beğenisini de kazandım,
takdirini de kazandım,
giydiklerimle ve saçımla tarz yarattım,
yeterince dikkat de çektim.
Peki mutlu oldum mu?
Hayır.
Hiçbir şekilde mutlu olmadım,
çünkü 60 milyonun onayı, takdiri
ve sevgisi değildi ihtiyacım olan.
Bir kişinin onayına, takdirine
ve sevgisine ihtiyacım vardı.
Kimin?
Aynen öyle, benim.
Bunu kesersiniz kurguda.
İkinci mesajım çok önemli:
Mutluluk arkasından koşarak
yakalayacağınız bir hedef değil,
mutluluk o anda
sizin yaratacağınız bir ruh hâlidir.
Yani önce mutlululuk, sonra başarı.
Birinci neydi: İçi kayıtlarla dolu,
şu anki hayatımızı yaratan
bir kara kutumuz var.
İkincisi: Önce mutluluk, sonra başarı.
Mutluluk arkasından koşularak
yakalanacak bir hedef değil.
Harvard profesörü Shawn Achor,
Mutluluk Avantajı kitabında
bunu deneylerle ispatlamış.
Önce başarı, sonra mutluluk;
yok öyle bir şey, deneylerle ispatlanmış.
Bakın size şöyle anlatayım.
Şimdi başarıyı buraya koyun,
yanına da mutluluğu koyun.
Buradan büyük bir azimle, benim gibi,
içeride de bir kayıt varsa sizi böyle
hırslı yapan, koşuyorsunuz koşuyorsunuz.
Geldiniz, başardınız.
Başarı, egonuzu tatmin ediyor
ve ego malesef çok açgözlü ve nankör.
Doymuyor, her daim daha fazlasını istiyor.
Tam buraya geldiniz,
"Başardım" dediniz,
egonuz tatmin oldu,
daha fazlasını istediniz.
Tık tık tık oraya gittiniz,
daha fazla istediniz.
Bu uu, oraya kadar gider.
Şimdi, mutluluğu
başarının yanına eşleştirirseniz
mutluluk sürekli sizden uzaklaşan
ve sizin yakalamaya çalışacağınız
bir hedef olacak.
Dolayısıyla ne diyoruz?
Önce mutluluk, sonra başarı.
Mesela dış faktörlerin yüzde kaçı
mutluluğumuzu etkiliyor, biliyor musunuz?
Bir yüzde tahmin edin.
Seyirci: On
Ee tabii, bir dakika kim o?
Sizi tanıyorum, haa bravo.
Sadece yüzde onu mutluluğumuzu etkiliyor.
Yüzde doksanı içsel faktörlerle alakalı.
Peki başarı ve dış faktörler
mutluluğumuzu etkilemiyor
içsel faktörler etkiliyorsa,
Hale mutluluk ne demek?
Mutluluk demek bence her daim
"Yehu" deyip enerjik olmak,
neşeli olmak,
sevinçli hissetmek demek değil.
Hayat inişlerle çıkışlarla dolu.
Benim mutluluk anlayışım;
top dibe vurduğunda,
hayat sizi en zor tecrübeyle sınadığında,
akşam yatağa başınızı koyduğunuzda
şükredecek tek bir şey bile
bulabiliyor musunuz?
Umut!
Tek bir şey bile var mı hayatınızda?
İşte mutluluk bu.
Hayatı ve hayatın size sunduğu
tüm deneyimleri nasıl kucaklamaya
karar veriyorsunuz,
mutluluk bu.
Mutluluğun bilimsel açıklaması,
pozitif psikoloji.
Peki, ikinci sordukları soru:
Nereden başlayacağız,
nasıl olacak bu iş?
Yine yapılan
bütün bilimsel araştırmalar diyor ki,
kendi mutluluğunuzun önündeki
en büyük engel sadece ve sadece biziz.
Bu yüzden kendimizden başlayacağız.
Önce bir aynada gerçek hâlimizi göreceğiz.
Ben bunu şöyle bir örnekle anlatıyorum:
Dişçiye gittiniz, aramızda
diş hekimleri varsa çok eğlenecek.
Kocaman güzel bir gülümseme istiyorsunuz,
çok mutlu ve şık gözüken,
ama dişinizde bir sürü böyle lekeler var,
siyah siyah, çürük çürük.
Ee, dişçi ne yapıyor?
Yani gidip de hemen üstten görünenleri
kazıyıp üzerini kaplamıyor.
Panoramik röntgeninizi çekiyor.
Üstten gözüken çürüklerin altında
hangi iltihaplar var,
kanal tedavisi gerekiyor mu,
diş çekilmesi gerekiyor mu?
Dipte neler var, onları görmek için
panoramik röntgeninizi çekiyor.
İşte ben de diyorum ki zihinsel olarak,
ruhsal olarak, duygusal olarak
ve fiziksel olarak panoramik röntgeninizi
çekin ya da çektirin.
Bunun için artık milyon tane
kişisel gelişim öğretisi var,
seminerleri var, atölyeleri var,
çalışmaları var.
Eğer ruhsal sağlığınız yerinde değilse
profesyonel destek alacağınız
terapistler var.
Ruhsal sağlığınız yerinde,
sadece biraz yönlendirmeye
ihtiyacınız varsa koçlar var.
Ama bir sürü şey var,
yeter ki siz aksiyon almaya karar verin.
Çünkü aslında her şey
ve her şey sadece düşüncede bitiyor.
Bir düşüncemiz var.
Her şey düşünceyle başlıyor.
Bu düşünce giderek su damlası gibi,
önce küçücük bir su damlası,
sonra birikinti oluyor,
göl oluyor, okyanus oluyor.
Düşünceler birikiyor, birikiyor
ve biz de birtakım duygulara neden oluyor.
Duygular ve hisler yaratıyor.
Biz bu duygular ve hislerin etkisinde
bazı davranışları gösteriyoruz
ve hayatta bu duyguların
kontrolünde, seçimler yapıyoruz.
Bu duygular ve seçimlerin sonucunda da
hayat tecrübemiz ortaya çıkıyor.
Peki hayat tecrübemizde neler var?
Şöyle bir grupladım genel olarak:
Sağlık ve bedenimiz,
aile ve ilişkiler,
iş-başarı,
eğlence-keyif,
bolluk-bereket.
Şimdi,
şurada mutlu olmadığınız
ya da daha iyi olabileceğinize inandığınız
bir alan mı var?
Dönüp gideceğiniz yer,
hangi düşünceyle
ben bu gerçeği yarattım?
Böyle düşünmeniz gerekiyor,
çünkü süreç böyle.
Heal your life öğretisinin büyük hayat
öğretmeni Louise Hay,
nur içinde yatsın,
der ki, "Düşünceni değiştir,
hayat tecrübeni değiştir."
Ben bu düşünce değiştirme,
dönüşüm işine bildiğiniz gibi değil
bayağı kafayı taktım, yeni kariyerim oldu.
Çünkü bütün umudu bunda görüyorum.
Diyeceksiniz, çok mu umutsuzsun?
Hayır, aksine çok umudum var
ama artık sınırları çok zorladığımız
bir yere geldiğimize inanıyorum.
Çünkü insanoğlu
kendini yok etme programında çalışıyor.
Dünya bizim evimiz,
ama dikkat edin biz ev sahibi değiliz,
biz kiracıyız.
Geliyoruz, gidiyoruz;
geliyoruz, gidiyoruz.
Şimdi hayal edin:
Şahane çok güzel bir eviniz var, rüya gibi
ve içine çok sevdiğiniz insanları
kiracı olarak yerleştiriyorsunuz.
Gel gör ki kiracılar evinize
çok kötü davranıyor.
Bir mesaj gönderiyorsunuz, uyarıyorsunuz.
İkinci mesajı gönderiyorsunuz,
uyarıyorsunuz.
Üçüncü mesajı gönderiyorsunuz,
Ama o sevdiğiniz insanlar bir türlü
uyanıp akıllanıp bilinçlenmiyor
ve hâlâ evinize zarar vermeye
devam ediyor.
Evinizi kaybetme noktasına gelirseniz
ne yaparsınız?
Kiracıya yallah! Evinizi kurtarırsınız.
O yüzden lütfen dikkat edelim,
biz bu dünyada kiracıyız.
Ev sahibinin bizi kovmasını istemiyorsak,
üç, şimdi hatırlayalım.
Bir, ne dedik:
Hepimizin hayatını oluşturan
bir kara kutu var içi kayıtlarla dolu.
İki: Önce mutluluk, sonra başarı.
Başarı bir hedef olamaz
arkasından koşulacak.
Üç:
Ev sahibinin
bizi evden atmasını istemiyorsak,
insan olmayı hatırlama zamanı.
İnsan olmayı hatırlama zamanı.
Hepimizi çok ilginç bir gelecek bekliyor.
Yapay zekânın ve robotların hâkim olacağı
bir gelecekte yaşayacağız.
Hadi bizi geçin,
çocuklarımız ve torunlarımız yetenekleri,
yetileri ve becerileriyle
bu süper tasarlanmış
mekanik araçlarla yarışacaklar.
Biz robotları insanlaştırmaya çalışırken,
ki bunu şahane yapıyoruz,
en son ne yaptık birine makyaj yaptık,
peruk taktık, kapak kızı yaptık!
Vatandaşlık verdik bir de!
Biz, robotları insanlaştırırken
insanlar robotlaştık.
İşte tam da bu yüzden
tüm bizi insan yapan değerlerimizi
hatırlama zamanı geldi,
çünkü onlar robotlarla olmayacak.
Yani özümüze dönmemiz gerekiyor.
Özgüven, özdeğer, özsaygı, özsevgi.
Bunlar çok önemli diyoruz,
bunları güçlendirmek için
çocuklarımıza vermek için
ne kadar çok emek sarf ediyoruz.
Peki, soruyorum:
Gerçekten tanımadığınız,
gerçekliğini bilmediğiniz bir kişiye
ne kadar güvenirsiniz?
Ne kadar seversiniz,
ne kadar değer verirsiniz?
Ne kadar saygı duyarsınız?
İngilizce'de öze "self" demişler,
yani kendin.
Kendini ne kadar iyi tanıyorsun?
Kendi gerçekliğini
ne kadar iyi biliyorsun?
İşte o yüzden benim için
özüne dönmek demek,
kendi gerçekliğinle tanışmak demek.
Ailelerimiz tarafından, toplum tarafından
üzerimize bir sürü gömlek giydiriliyor.
Olmamız gerekenler, yapmamız gerekenler,
sorumluluklar, zorunluluklar;
bir sürü gömlek var!
Kendin olmak, özüne dönmek demek
bence o gömleklerden bir bir sıyrılıp
gerçek seni keşfetmek demek.
Zaten dünya da bizden bunu bekliyor.
Eğer dünya danışanım olarak
ofisime gelip karşıma otursaydı
ve deseydi ki,
dünya deyince
geri çekilme hissi hissettim saygıdan,
"Hale ben kendimi hiç iyi hissetmiyorum,
bana koç olarak
nasıl yardımcı olabilirsin?"
İlk sorum şu olurdu:
Sevgili Dünya, şu anki durumun nedir?
Anlatırdı.
Dünyanın şu anki durumunu
hepimiz biliyoruz.
Sonra ikinci sorum şu olurdu:
Peki, sevgili Dünya
olmak istediğin hâl nedir?
Onu da anlatırdı.
Hepimiz onu da biliyoruz.
Sonra üçüncü aşama gelirdi, üçüncü soru:
Peki sevgili Dünya,
buradan buraya ulaşmak için
aradaki engelin nedir?
Teşekkür ederim, evet.
Aradaki engel biziz: İnsanoğlu.
Sonra bir sonraki soru gelirdi,
sormaya korkuyorum,
çünkü ucu hepimize dokunacak.
Sevgili Dünya,
buraya ulaşmana engel olan
insanoğlunu veya engeli
ortadan kaldırmak için
ne gibi bir çözümler düşünürsün?
İnsanoğlunu yok etmek.
Bakınız, Nuh Tufanı.
Bilimsel olarak bir sürü veri var,
Dünya'nın ırkımızı yok etmesi
bir güne bakar.
Sevgili Dünya, başka çözüm yok mu?
Olmaz mı?
Çözüm insanoğlunda.
İnsanoğlu artık uyansın
ve sorumluluk üstlensin.
Robotlara insan gibi davranmayı
ve düşünmeyi öğreteceğine,
kendisi insan olmayı hatırlayıp
düşünce gücünün farkına varsın.
Şu an burada oturan her biriniz
ve ekranı karşısında dinleyen sen.
Hepimizin dünyayı
ve insanlığı kurtarma gücü içinde,
ben buna sonsuz inanıyorum.
"Ben kimim ki dünyayı
ya da insanlığı kurtaracağım?"
Sen kimsin ki yapmayacaksın?
"Bir kişiden ne fark eder?"
İnsanoğlunun tümü zaten
birer kişinin toplamı değil mi?
Çok şey fark eder.
O yüzden, şu anki dünyanızdan
memnun mu değilsiniz?
Şu anki dünyayı
iyileştirmek mi istiyorsunuz?
Şu anki dünyayı beğenmiyorsunuz,
değiştirmek mi istiyorsunuz?
Sevgili insanoğlu,
sen değiş, dünyan değişsin.
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)